christopher a uh brilliant uh four and a
half out of five brilliant start for you
congratulations first of all how does
that feel great
going into the rest day uh one point it
seems like if mishra manages to win this
one against andrew hong how would you
assess your chances
to take the title christopher
i feel like my chances are pretty good
obviously
absolutely yes well let's discuss
today's game in that case
christopher take us through the opening
phase
you came up with this blumenfeld gambit
how did you come up with this strategy
i just wanted to get a complicated fun
game so i thought it made sense to do
some sort of gambit or something
but the blue nfl gambit usually you see
a couple of games at the top level and
then it just disappears for the next
five years
you wanted to bring it back into the
mainstream
yeah i guess
and it seemed like it worked were you
surprised by this movie e5 because we
were
yeah it was it was definitely kind of
funny because right after i tried to
gambit it's like he wants to gambit back
just to
be on even grounds but i didn't really
think it made that much sense to gambit
his central pawn
and let's keep going with the next few
moves because i think not as much has
happened after that another big decision
after bishop to e2
rook to e8 you put the knight on f3 did
you consider at all knight to d3
and keep the f file open for it
potentially your rook
i did i think i was slightly concerned
about knight e4 94 and castle
which definitely looks a bit dangerous
yeah queen to h4 knight to f4 i thought
maybe g5 g5 and you are worried about
this yeah
makes sense makes sense well i think
perhaps g3 you can take on g3 right yeah
yeah complicated position definitely
after this vicious attack coming your
way but you decided to go knight to f3
what was your assessment at this point
of the position
did you feel like you're in full control
not really but i think i preferred why
preferred white of course always a good
idea to be confident in your position
let's keep going
tell us the next critical moment
christopher
um
maybe
h3 was a critical moment
h3 yeah
how come
because knight d5 looked very natural
but i was slightly concerned about takes
on d5 and then knight before
i took b4 and now
it's not that easy to defend this d5
pawn it seems like yeah
okay
h3 critical moment uh let's keep going
let's keep going and uh i think we
we were analyzing your position and
trying to understand
how you should break through at this
point rook to f4 you came up with this
idea to transfer the rook on the g file
root to g4
now
this was probably his
last chance instead of h5 knight to e6
did you consider this move
yeah i thought i can just take the pawn
on b7 oh bishop takes b we did not even
look that direction
bishop takes p7 guys the training is not
working yasser
we did not even consider this bishop
takes b7 what's wrong with us
nothing's wrong with taking upon
christopher i don't know what your
problem is take the bun listen to
christopher i like it
bishop takes b7 probably would have kept
an advantage in uh this one he played
the move h5 and after that
you converted nicely christopher
congratulations big victory for you big
start in the first five rounds
guys any questions no congratulations
christopher four and a half outstanding
result keep it up and uh we'll see on
the other side of the rest day
thank you
welcome